-Guys, a lot of people
are talking about
President Biden's $1.7 trillion
infrastructure plan.
[ Panting ] I'm out of breath.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why I can't do
an action movie.
I can't do an action movie.
I do one scene,
and, "We got to get you
out of here."
Then I'm huffing and puffing
in the corner.
That's what happens when you see
the Jack Fallon movie --
Jake Fallon.
-Jake Fallon.
-The Jake Fallon movie.
-The whole series the fantastic.
-Well, we had to put it
in three parts,
'cause I couldn't breathe
through the whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
-COPD.
-He said two sentences.
Yeah. Well, there's
a lot to know about it.
There's also a lot
of misinformation
about the infrastructure plan.
-Really?
-Yeah, which means it's time
for "Fact vs Fiction."
Here we go.
-♪ Fact ♪
♪ Fact or fiction ♪
-So, let's get started.
First up, fact --
The plan will cost
$1.7 trillion.
Fiction -- But if Biden
spends $1.8 trillion,
he gets free shipping.
That's fiction.
That's not true. No.
-That is not true.
-Next up, fact --
Biden aims to fix many of the
country's old roads and bridges.
Fiction --
He plans to do most of it
with his bulk order
of Flex Seal.
-Wow.
[ Imitates spraying ]
-Here's another one. Fact --
Biden's plan includes funding
for broadband Internet.
Fiction -- Republicans' plan
includes a barrel
of free AOL CDs.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Five hours?
-Next up, we have fact --
The bill is called
the "Build Back Better Plan."
Fiction -- If you can say
"Build Back Better Plan"
five times fast,
you get to drive the crane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"We're building America!"
"Jake Fallon
behind the wheel of a crane."
-Yeah. Maybe that's how
my character gets around.
-Yeah, crane -- All sorts --
Man, he knows how to drive
everything, fly everything.
-I like that that's his vehicle,
is a crane.
Like, "There's no way
Jake Fallon knows we're here.
What's that crane doing here?"
-[ Imitates machine whirring ]
-"It's raining.
What's that neon sign say?"
-Oh, my God. It's rain water!
-"We got to get you
out of here!"
♪♪
-"Jake Fallon."
-Is that the name of it?
-What's that?
-What's the name of it?
-The first movie?
-"Somewhere to Run."
-"Somewhere to Run"
is the first movie.
"Blood Moon"
was the second movie.
-"Insane in the Membrane."
-Insane in the main crane?
-"Insane in the Main Crane."
-Insane in the crane.
-Yeah. Here's another fact here.
Biden wants to fund the plan by
raising taxes on corporations.
Fiction --
Additional money would be raised
by turning the Pentagon into the
world's largest Johnny Rockets.
That's not true.
Next up, we have fact --
$1.7 trillion can be spent
on fixing roads, building
schools, and rebuilding America.
Fiction -- Or one new
printer ink cartridge.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Not so far, not so far.
-Here's another fact -- The plan
will upgrade federal buildings.
Fiction -- The plan will include
adding a swim-up bar
in the White House.
They're fun!
-Come on, they're fun.
-They're fun.
Finally, fact --
Biden lowered the price
of his infrastructure plan
to $1.7 trillion.
Fiction -- If you act now,
he'll throw in
a complimentary tote bag.
That's all the time we have
for "Fact vs Fiction."
We'll be right back with
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Come on back, everybody.
-In a world
where nothing was fact,
nothing was fiction,
one man dared
to give you somewhere...